♪♪
-I thought last week
was really good.
[ Laughter ]
It was the kind
of "Corrections" episode
that I think best represents
what we're trying to do here.
And when people say to me,
"Where should I start?"
I want to be able
to say episode 82,
but I know that I'm going
to follow up saying,
"But there's a lot of stuff
in 81 that sets it up.
And if you're going to watch 81,
you just got to watch --"
And at some point you're like,
"Start from the beginning."
And it's a day.
[ Laughter ]
You're asking people
for a human day.
So, you know, look,
I'm glad you're here
because I don't think
we're picking up new people.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
I think it's us.
And it's just --
it's going to --
It's just going to
slowly degrade over time
just as people, you know, age
out, rest in peace situation.
[ Laughter ]
The prime minister
of Australia's name
is pronounced
Anthony "Alban-ase"--
"Alban-easy."
Albanese, rhymes with "easy."
I just wish there was
a simple way to remember that.
[ Light laughter ]
Well, you know, we were
talking about him
because we were joking
that the state dinner,
he had a state dinner
at the White House
and the White House
served beetroot.
And we were saying
that's insulting.
You know, to have
a world leader over
and give him something as
uninteresting as beetroot.
And then a bunch of you
wrote beetroot
is very common
in Australian cuisine,
so it was appropriate to serve.
And hey, I get it.
If they ever threw a dinner
for me at the White House,
I would definitely want them
to make stuff I have at home.
[ Laughter ]
"We can do anything you want.
We're the White House."
"You got a pantry?
I'd love to quietly eat
a handful of almonds
in the dark."
[ Laughter ]
I hope this doesn't come off as
critical of Australian cuisine.
I love --
I'm going out
for Australian tonight.
[ Laughter ]
Can't get enough of it.
When I go on Seamless
or GrubHub,
I just always go
to that cuisine tab,
see what my local Australian
has for the night.
I have so much respect
for Australian chefs
because pretty much
every creature that lives there,
if you cook it
and serve it to a person,
that act in any other country
in the world
is considered attempted murder.
[ Laughter ]
When an Australian waiter
comes to your table,
the first thing they say is
"Before I tell you the specials,
is anyone here a cop?"
[ Laughter ]
I did my Australian waiter
in my regular voice
because the feedback
was I have
a terrible Australian accent.
It was bad last week.
It was bad last week because
I did not do my vocal warm-ups
that I need to do
for my Australian accent,
and I did not
do my vocal warm-ups
because I'm told it's very
unsettling to watch me do them.
Like, [Grunting]
[ Laughter ]
It's like that for 10 minutes.
Oh, I mentioned in
"A Closer Look" yesterday
that I went to see
"PAW Patrol 2" this weekend,
and I intimated that I did not
enjoy it, but that is my fault
that I didn't enjoy it because
I never saw "PAW Patrol 1."
[ Laughter ]
So I was having a real hard time
just following it.
[ Laughter ]
That movie is very ploddy.
That's ploddy with two D's.
[ Laughter ]
I just didn't quite understand
why these dogs could talk.
Why they were being funded by
the military industrial complex.
I don't mind when animals
talk in movies.
I just don't like
when they can talk to people.
There have to be rules.
We had a picture of Donald Trump
shoplifting
an "Us Weekly" in yesterday's
"Closer Look" as well.
And a bunch of you complained
because he was putting a
"Us Weekly" --
he was stealing a Kit Kat.
And a bunch of you
said his hands
in the graphic were too big.
And so I pulled it up.
I don't -- I don't know,
I sometimes feel like
you're -- you think like I like
when you call out graphics
and their errors,
but I don't know.
I think it's fine.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we had the "leave him alone"
guy on the show this week,
and someone said
he tapped his phone
when it was clearly
a slide-to-answer situation.
We apologize. And next Monday
to make it up to you,
we're going to do
the whole thing again.
[ Laughter ]
Start to finish.
Hey, we made a joke about Pepsi.
We had a Pepsi fan
who took umbrage
and said our joke fell flat.
Just like Pepsi.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like I did a good job
saying "pleading" this week
instead of "pled."
But I did let
a "pled" slip in once,
and for that I apologize.
We've spent a lot of time
already talking about
the correct past tense for
"plea."
I don't want to
get into it again.
Just know that
if I make a mistake,
we will catch it internally.
We're trying to correct it.
We're trying to get it right.
If you hear it again, just --
just let it go.
Please.
I am "pledding" with you.
[ Laughter ]
Someone wrote in a criticism,
"Making fun of elders,
is this what passes
as comedy now?"
Elders?
[ Laughter ]
How old are you?
Also, someone wrote
in "Corrections" --
this is a comment
"So, the writers
are still on strike?"
Rude.
We joked you could lure Trump
into a pan --
into a van, into a pan.
Ooh.
Maybe they didn't notice.
[ Laughter ]
We joked you could lure Trump
into a van with a puppy.
Many of you correctly
pointed out
that Trump hates dogs so much,
that wouldn't work
unless you said it like,
"Hey, kid.
You want to see us [bleep]
with this poodle?"
[ as Trump ]
I would like to see that.
I'm a little kid.
I'd love to see that.
[ Normal voice ]
Ken Chesebro.
He said "I'm guilty" this week.
He aid it in a courtroom.
And because of Ken
Chesebro's name,
we said --
We made a run of jokes
about cheese-based Hasbro toys.
One of them was Barbrie.
Barbie is Mattel.
I got her confused with that
other doll, Oppenheimer.
[ Laughter ]
My Little Pony is Hasbro,
which was the other one.
I made a joke,
My Little Provolone.
Killed.
[ Laughter ]
One of you wrote, "That joke
doesn't work
because the E
in 'provolone' is silent."
You know what else is silent?
The audience
the day I let you
write my punch lines.
[ Laughter ]
I also want to stress
in case you like that,
this isn't going to become
a sort of cheese-pun place.
That was that. That's over,
because I could tell
that was bouncing around
the Internet like, "Hey, whoa!
I thought he just did
political jokes,
but there are some good --
good cheese puns."
We said Trump's lumpy coat
looks like a guy
trying to sneak a bunch of kids
into an R-rated movie.
A bunch of you pointed out he
wouldn't need to sneak them in
because they just have to be
with a guardian,
so he could just
bring them in, but that assumes
that Trump
wants to pay for their tickets.
I said the plural of Pegasus
was Pegasi.
Pegasus is a proper name,
and even if it wasn't,
the plural would be Pegasuses.
Pegasi would be if it was Roman,
but it's Greek.
Pegasus was created
when it sprang
from the neck of a Medusa
after she was beheaded
by Perseus.
That was unique
to that Medusa.
It doesn't happen
to every Medusi.
[ Laughter ]
Have you tried the new Medusa
cheese, Shoemaker?
[ Laughter ]
Gorgonzola.
Speaking of Shoemaker,
I went to his daughter's
wedding this Saturday.
Oh, my God, what a night.
Beautiful, beautiful wedding.
Beautiful bride.
Here's the thing though.
I've worked with Shoemaker
for over 20 years.
Everyone in my life knows
how close we are, knows
how important he is to me.
There's not a person I know that
wouldn't be able to tell you
everything about Mike Shoemaker.
I go to this wedding.
I'm meeting his neighbors,
cousins, his family, friends.
Every person there walks up
to me and says,
"Seth Meyers?
What are you doing here?"
[ Laughter ]
To a person.
And I'm like,
"Oh, Mike's the producer
of my television show."
And they're like,
"Mikey the Shoe?"
[ Laughter ]
Like, not only do these people
not know he's a TV producer,
like, they can't believe
he has a TV.
[ Laughter ]
They're all like, "A producer?
We thought he cleaned
swimming pools."
And then I catch his eye
across the room,
and he's giving me one of these,
like...
[ Laughter ]
I walk over, I go, "What?"
He goes,
"Stop blowing up my spot."
I go, "What are you
talking about?
Why do you not want these
people to know what you do?"
He goes, "It's none
of their business."
And I go, "What do you
tell them you are?"
And then he says to me,
"Dead broke."
[ Laughter ]
"You think they'd lend me money
if they know what I do
for a living?"
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like,
"But you have money."
And he goes,
"You can never have enough."
And that's not -- At a wedding.
[ Laughter ]
Main takeaway though,
it was amazing.
Katherine, his daughter,
a beautiful bride.
Married a wonderful guy.
Very funny comedian
named Mike Antonucci.
And I remember my wedding day
and how much I wish
I could live it over again.
And I walked over to the groom
and I put a hand on his shoulder
because I wanted to tell him,
"Don't let this day fly by."
And I put my hand
on his shoulder.
He slaps it away
and he turns around.
He goes, "Oh, Mikey the Duch,
don't like
when you touch the merchandise."
I'm like, "Oh [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
[Bleep] Hey, man.
A pumpkin is a pumpkin.
A jack-o'-lantern is a carved
pumpkin with a light in it,
and a jackal lantern
is a pumpkin
that criticizes trick-or-treater
costumes
when they come
to the front door.
They're like, "Eh, actually,
Harry Potter
wouldn't wear New Balance."
[ Laughter ]
Somebody wrote this.
We've been talking about venom
versus poison.
Somebody wrote,
"Venom usually isn't poisonous,
so ingesting venom
wouldn't kill you
unless you had some sort of open
wound in your digestive tract
so the venom
got in your blood."
Well, I thought
that was assumed,
but if you want me
to say that every time.
[ Laughter ]
I also talked about
the differential --
I tried to differentiate
between ingested and injected,
and I put the emphasis
on the syllable they share.
I was like,
"IN-gested means this."
And then I went
"IN-jected means this."
And that's not
the way you do it.
You stress the difference.
It'd be like saying,
"Oh, JEFF Daniels.
I thought you meant
JEFF Bridges."
[ Laughter ]
I said "doth" is how people
talk at ren fairs.
It's doth[duth].
So the correct usage
would be "Doth
the candlemaker taketh Visa?"
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
This really --
I couldn't believe
how many of you did this.
Talked about "Silence
of the Lambs" last week,
called Hannibal Lecter
the villain.
Way, way too many of you said
Buffalo Bill is the villain.
Hannibal Lecter is the antihero.
If you're not his lawyer,
shut the [bleep] up about that.
[ Laughter ]
Somebody wrote he only bit
one person in that movie.
Oh, well, in that case,
I guess he can babysit my kids.
[ Laughter ]
And look, I'm not defending
Buffalo Bill.
The man is unwell.
He's so unwell,
he has an actual well.
[ Laughter ]
That's a red flag.
If you're ever
at someone's house
and they have an inside well,
get out.
I also --
I talked about Hannibal Lecter's
security guards,
and someone said,
"Hey, it sounds like --
his prison guards sound like
your security guys,
John and Jim."
That would be my [bleep] dream.
[ Laughter ]
If John and Jim were Hannibal
Lecter's security guards,
it would --
I would run to work each Monday
to hear the stories
from those two guys
about being the prison guards
for Hannibal Lecter.
I would run to work.
John would be,
"You're not going to believe
what happened this weekend, sir.
Hannibal Lecter tricks us."
[ Laughter ]
"Gets out of his cuffs,
bites Jim."
I'm like, "Oh, my God,
is Jim okay?"
"Jim's fine.
Hannibal Lecter's teeth [bleep]
shattered."
[ Laughter ]
"And he bites -- I guess
he bites a lot of people,
but he never bit anybody
like Jim before."
"Yeah. You don't --
You don't want to bite me."
[ Laughter ]
"You don't want to bite me."
"Can I tell you something, Seth?
His drawings. This guy Lecter,
his drawings are good."
[ Laughter ]
"His drawings.
I mean, Agent Starling,
she's been here one, two times.
Looks like a picture of her."
[ Laughter ]
"What does he do, Jim?
Is it charcoal?"
"Graphite.
It's a graphite pencil."
[ Laughter ]
I said a gavel banged
on a podium.
I corrected that to a gavel
bangs on a lectern.
And then I was told the gavel
actually makes contact,
with what is called
a sound block or a gavel plinth.
Maybe and I mean maybe
I'll say sound block,
but I'm never saying "gavel
plinth" in front of this crew.
[ Laughter ]
If I said plinth on this show,
Kenny Coyle would pants me
in the hallway.
[ Laughter ]
Plinth.
With this lot.
[ Laughter ]
I got pigeons and gulls
mixed up last week.
I know gulls are the ones
that eat your food on the beach.
Best version I've ever seen
of that -- two summers ago,
my son Axel has a bagel.
He is running down the beach.
He is holding his bagel
in the air like this.
He is in such -- He's so happy
that he has a bagel
and he's running towards us.
We have our towel set up.
Biggest smile on his face,
and a gull
swoops down, takes the bagel
out of his hand, and flies away.
It looked like it was
something in a [bleep] circus.
People gasped.
A lot of people saw it.
They would have applauded
at what the gull had done,
swooping down
and grabbing a bagel
out of a running child's hand.
The only reason they didn't
applaud is Axel was sobbing,
and I had to go over
and be like,
"I know you're upset.
An amazing thing just happened."
[ Laughter ]
"You're sad about your bagel,
but a great --
a thing
I will never forget happened."
[ Laughter ]
We also talked about whether
these beach birds
are seagulls or herring gulls.
So I described this one
to an ornithologist.
The one that did that
to Axel is a ba-gull[bagel].
[ Laughter ]
I'll wait.
The chair declares
this "Correction" in recess
subject to the call
of the chair.
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
I almost forgot.
We discussed whether Stevie
Nicks wore scarves or shawls.
We decided she wore shawls.
And she tied scarves
around her mike stand.
The reason she doesn't
wear scarves is interesting.
I guess she has a condition
where her
cervical spine lacks strength.
And so it's not healthy
to wrap anything around it.
This whole area just sort of
lacks a structural integrity.
To put it in layman terms,
Stevie's neck's weak.
[ Laughter ]